er bringt ihr oberleutnant schmidt
meldet den einzigen druck der gerade ein
bläserquintett ja gerade musik und 124
tun wird sich nach dessen rückkehr -
märz 2020 zur feierlichen akt
[Musik]
ja
heute stehen wir hier gemeinsam und
erleben eine angelobung der im wahrsten
sinne des wortes ganz besonderen art
so wie sie hier vermutlich in allen
steigt aber auch für die garde noch nie
in dieser form gegeben hat ohne eltern
ohne verwandte freunde bekannte
werden sie in kürze ihr treuegelöbnis
auf die republik österreich ablegen
zu diesem zwecke heiß ich als besondere
ehrengäste die soldaten der ersten
kompanie herzlich willkommen die
gesundheitskrise in bezug auf das corona
virus stellt uns alle vor neue
herausforderungen
wir leben nun seit einiger zeit mit
ausgangs beschränkungen vorgaben in der
ausbildung auf neudeutsch social
distance macht auch hier beim
österreichischen bundesheer keine
ausnahme sie sind anfang märz noch unter
anderen vorzeichen zur garde in die
maria theresien kaserne eingerückt und
bereits am ersten tag planmäßig nach
hohen haben sie zur ausbildung verlegt
die nal weniger tage hat sich die lage
aber sehr schnell verändert so mussten
sie bereits in der zweiten
ausbildungswoche eine kurze quarantäne
phase nach einem verdachtsfall in der
kompanie erleben und haben das gemeinsam
sehr gut gemeistert
zur erfüllung der vorgaben und auflagen
ist sind sie aber jetzt hier in allen
stimmlagen kaufholz hier kann ihre
ausbildung und fallen die unterbringung
und der rücksicht maßnahme der maßnahmen
zum schutz ihrer gesundheit bestmöglich
durchgeführt werden
die garde ein verband mit doppelten
auftrag einsatz und repräsentation seit
dem beginn der krise stehen wir mit
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz zur bewältigung dieser
herausforderung achten sie meine sehr
geehrten herrn
auf sich und ihre kameraden bei der
ausbildung halten sie abstand wo es
möglich ist
sie leisten mit ihren grundwehrdienst
als teil des systems österreich einen
wesentlichen beitrag zur bewältigung
dieser krise und zur unterstützung der
österreichischen bevölkerung
ich wünsche ihnen ihren verwandten
bekannten freunden alles gute für die
nächsten tage wochen und monate
und das wichtigste bleiben sie gesund
ich danke der heiligen schrift gibt es
im römerbrief ein zitat dort heißt es
nimmt einander an wie auch christus uns
angenommen hat auch den jüngsten
soldaten die in dieser zeit heute die
gelöbnisformel sprechen werden sei daher
jetzt schon gedankt für ihren einsatz
und ihren dienst
liebe kameraden sie geloben feierlich
mit allen ihren kräften der republik
österreich und dem österreichischen volk
zu dienen nimmt einander an der soldaten
dienst erlaubt keine gleichgültigkeit
denn die ganze welt leidet und muss sich
bei der bekämpfung dieser pandemie
zusammenschließen kameraden diese zeit
erlaubt keinen egoismus
denn die herausforderung vor der wir
stehen ist uns allen gemeinsam und macht
auch keine unterschiede
ich wünsche euch und ihnen für die
kommenden monate ihrer zeit beim
österreichischen bundesheer deshalb viel
soldatenglück vor allem gelebte
kameradschaft kraft und hoffnung sowie
eine gesinnung des einander annehmen
gott segne sie und bewahre sie vor
unheil bleiben sie gesund gottes segen
sei mit ihnen zurück darf ich mich
bedanken dass es sich für diesen dienst
beim bundesheer entschieden haben
unter ganz anderen voraussetzungen
anderen vorzeichen wie das was hier
gegner und unsere mehrfacher bereits
angesprochen haben und deshalb ist auch
diese angelobung
eine wirklich bemerkenswerte nicht nur
ohne ihre angehörigen eine ehrenkompanie
ohne ehrengäste und statt einer
blasmusikkapelle ein quintett das das
aber ganz ausgezeichnet durch wird sie
sprechen in kürze ihre treuegelöbnis und
dabei versprechen sie dass sie
persönlich einen beitrag dazu leisten
werden dass die österreichische
bevölkerung geschützt wird und mit
diesem treuegelöbnis stehen sie auch in
guter kameradschaft mit ihren kameraden
hintergarten da kann man unter gerade
hat das auch ganz kurz angesprochen was
derzeit alles gemacht wird in der garde
und das ist wirklich herausragend das
sind gewaltige aufgaben
derzeit stehen und es gibt keinen
verband in österreich der diese große
aufgabenpalette zu erfüllen hat und mein
dank gilt hier die sehr geehrte obacht
das kann man ander gerade mit allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
sie diese jetzt angelobt werden stehen
nicht nur daneben sind nicht nur
irgendwie dabei sondern sie sind mitten
drin weil ganz klar ist dass auch sie
entsprechende aufgaben in kürze zu
übernehmen haben werden
und egal welche aufgaben für sie auch
herr anstehen ich fordere sie auf dass
sie sich mit allen ihren persönlichen
kenntnissen ihren fähigkeiten und
fertigkeiten in diese aufgabenstellungen
hineinversetzen um sie mit allen
kenntnissen diese haben erfüllen werden
ich bin überzeugt dann werden auch sie
persönlich sehr viel von ihren
grundwehrdienst sehr viel positives mit
nach hause nehmen
für die vor ihnen liegenden
herausforderungen und tätigkeiten
wünsche ich ihnen als militärkommandant
vom wind alles erdenklich gute
zum wohl der bundeshauptstadt und ihrer
bevölkerung und zum wohl unserer heimat
der republik österreich
ich wünsche ihm alles erdenklich gute
und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]
rekrut dann spricht mir nach ich glaube
mein vaterland die republik österreich
und burg zu schützen und mit der waffe
zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen und den
gesetzmäßigen behörden
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
[Applaus]
glücklich und genau zu befolgen und mit
allen meine kräfte der republik
österreich und am österreichischen folge
do